welcome to best life 30 your 30-day
journey to creating the best life
possible for yourself you can just watch
this video or if you want to sign up for
the whole series for free and get the
bonus companion worksheets that go with
each video check the link in the
description below alright so today is
day 9 and we're going to learn how you
can develop more discipline
[Music]
where does discipline
[Music]
discipline comes from within
it's a need
force
now sure of course you could have
discipline imposed on you by some person
like like a drill instructor
like that self-help
b-but the reality is that type of
discipline isn't the real type of
discipline that we're talking about that
discipline isn't as strong it won't
survive
what you need is self discipline our
self discipline comes from the self it
comes from you it comes from when you
make a decision to be disciplined when
you make a decision to be better when
you make a decision to do more and to be
more self discipline comes when you
decide that you're gonna make a mark on
the world and if you think
that you're not disappointed or you
can't be dissin it's because you haven't
yet decided to be disciplined it's
because you haven't needed that
discipline yet
[Music]
so make to this
make that commitment discipline the huge
quality that will improve every aspect
of your life
[Music]
stronger and smaller and faster
and most
it'll mean three
the other thing you should do if you're
not very industrious enough industrious
is discipline yourself and so what do
you do with that eat three times a day
at regular mealtimes that's a good thing
to practice because that starts to put
some stability into your life get up at
the same time I would highly recommend
all those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as I've got older I've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because I've
got more and more discipline like get up
early in the morning and get your things
done man you learn to get up at 6:00 in
the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look
Will Ferrell Warren Farrell not the
comedian Warren Farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book I would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13% longer
hours you make 40% more money it's
nonlinear so you think why is that well
imagine you have 10 employees and one of
them works an extra 10 percent it's not
much well how often is that person going
to be promoted assuming you have a clue
as a boss it's like you're gonna look at
the 10 people and the other thing all
that guys always hear like 45 minutes
early it's like why don't we give him
the promotion obviously right so these
tie these small Anja's that you can
manage like that work an extra 10% of
extra 13% have no unproportional payoffs
that's part of the Pareto distribution
so get get your sleep cycle organized so
you get up in the morning learn how to
do it
no excuses I'm too tired in the morning
I don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it schedule
your meals does that's a good
disciplinary routine and then learn to
use a calendar like Google Calendar most
of you many of you out there do not use
a calendar okay a calendar is not a
prison and it's not a tyrant not if you
use it properly a calendar keeps anxiety
at bay it makes sure that
you do what you need to do which is
important because otherwise you fall
behind but if you use it properly though
it's also helps you plan what you want
to do so I could say well lay out your
damn calendar and design the days you
would like to have that's what your
calendars have is for so you can put in
all sorts of things in there you want to
do and that would be good for you and
that's a really good really good way to
start being more industrious make a plan
you need a plan for three years you need
a plan for the next year you need to
plan for the next six months you need to
plan for the next three months you need
a plan for the week you need a plan for
the day you need to plan for the hour
all of that all of that I make lists
constantly of what I have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now I can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable I think to make vision
that's longer-term than that subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a ten-year goal but
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you gonna
do you're gonna stumble around and get
what you need
you're gonna stumble around and be
useful to other people and it's useful
to be useful to other people you know
they want to work with you then they
want to do things with you they want to
have you around they trust you they open
up opportunities for you and if you
stumble around like you're blind you're
not gonna get anywhere and then you're
gonna suffer and then you're gonna be
bitter and then you're gonna be cool so
that's a bit that's hell that's a bad
outcome but there are some actually keys
that very very disciplined people have
and here is the most important one and
this would change your life if you
do it and I had to make myself do this
it was not natural at all you must do
what you don't want to do first people
who are hugely successful do this they
do the thing they hate first of all I
worked with somebody who is morbidly
obese and I said you know you have to
work out when I hate working out you
know I'm heavy it's really uncomfortable
even got to do it you got to do it first
and I had to do that to see if you don't
like going to the gym you go I'll go
later then something happens the phone
rings you eat some of these it goes too
late now when you go first you think
later I've been I went to the gym first
I feel like a winner you got to make a
very difficult call gonna ring someone
who owes you money or confront someone
that you don't want to confront and you
wait and all day it's hanging over your
head making you feel so bad but when you
do it first you feel like a winner
because people who have discipline do
this they do the thing they do not want
to do first and I want you to start
saying that I was giving a speech
recently and the guy who came on after
me said you know I kept hearing my voice
of everything Marissa said do what you
don't want to do this I said that has
changed my entire business life and all
my staff remember that too what do we
not want to do what's the worst job
let's do that first and get it out of
the way and of course in the beginning
this will be what you do but you know
all happen it starts to become who you
are it becomes easy it becomes seamless
it's a bit like putting lenses
you're I feel seriously odd to suddenly
Jam your finger in your EIN but if you
do everyday comes easy because that I
don't have it so formed you make a habit
and then your habits make you so make
your habits amazing so I do scream to me
the other night a will I want to be
active man I will be active just like
you
you know usually people say stuff to me
like that I'm like yeah man you know you
do is give them an encouraging word but
I was just sitting here thinking and it
dawned on me 99% of people that say
stuff like that are not willing to do
what it takes to make their dreams come
true the Marines have a saying everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to die and that's just real at the
center of bringing any dream into
fruition is self-discipline you know
something something as simple as food
and eating it's not about your body as
much as it is about your mind it's
getting command of your mind to be able
to choose actions that are in your own
best interest every day we are choosing
[ __ ] that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you in the
world's trying to hold you down so
you're gonna kick yourself in the balls
so you will stop yourself from getting
what you dream self-discipline is the
center of all material success you
cannot win the war against the world if
you can't win the war against your own
mind
the thing about self-discipline is that
it is necessary for everything you do in
your life you have to be self discipline
if discipline comes from somewhere else
it's very very hard to remain consistent
because you tend to resist as well
because I see trainers and they're in
the gym with people and you know the guy
or girl that they're working out hates
their workout hates it because the
discipline is coming from somewhere else
you is something that you dread every
time
go in you don't really want to do it
it's like ah but oh no my trainers here
he's about to you know beat me up and
make me feel crazy well the truth is
every trainer should work his way out of
your life anybody who's working you out
your teachers your trainers your people
they have to train you to get out of
your life so you can go ahead do your
own workout do your own thing practice
self-discipline now one thing I want to
straighten out big-time discipline is
not punishment it's not discipline it's
training that's all it is I was talking
to my son one time and I asked him it
was weird because I was trying to see if
he really knew what it was all about and
I said hey man you know I have to
discipline you what is discipline he
goes punishment punishment when I do
something wrong and you punish me I was
like no no discipline is training if you
change your mind your mindset and really
focus it on what discipline really is
you start to welcome discipline you
welcome self discipline into your life I
believe that most human beings are only
living at about 40 percent of their
capability so the mind has a governor
like a car if you're driving a car and
the car has a governor on it the car may
say hundred thirty miles an hour but the
governor set 491 once that governor sets
in you get the 91 that car starts doing
this the car wants to go the car wants
to go but that factory said uh we're not
going past 91 we have a factory a nice
governor in our brain and it's a
survival mechanism it protects us from
pain and suffering the second we feel
that our mind says no no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable
and there's some about the mind the mind
has the tactical advantage over you at
all times at all times of your life the
mind has a tactical advantage over you
why is that it knows what you're afraid
of it knows your insecurities it knows
your deep dark lies
and it starts to push you away from that
it pushes you in a direction that is
comfortable the mind controls everything
so what I realized was that when I was
growing up and I was 300 pounds and I
got all fat and I got all insecure I
realized that my mind kept taking me in
this direction when things got
uncomfortable for me when I was facing
my insecurities I was facing my fears my
mind said oh no we have the tactical
advantage we just get you separates you
from this feeling this feeling of your
life's all about feelings we want the
happy feeling we don't want that feeling
of this sucks why am I here and you
don't have any choice oh you can't
answer those questions so you leave I
started realizing that if in that moment
you can answer those tough questions and
you are now in charge of your brain
versus your brain ruling you that's
where all that stuff comes from so the
40% rule is all of that you get to 40%
your brain says we're done let's roll
man this is start to get painful this is
uncomfortable so you sit down you have
to figure out ways and everybody's
different that's how the book kind of
talks about like we all have these
things about you know five steps to this
and four steps to this it's it's a lot
more than that that's all [ __ ] it's
it's a practice that you have to it's a
habit so if you know that forty percent
I'm still you know I'm feeling pain at
40 percent feeling pain that's where the
40 percent rule kicks in now it starts
okay I'm feeling pain my mind's saying
all this to me it's saying get out of
here run flee the fight-or-flight kicks
in okay we're done we're not good enough
and starts telling you all these things
you start to believe it because the mind
controls all this is the time where you
have to gain control back of your mind
it said okay let me see if I can go 45
percent and once you start giving
yourself more and more hope and start
realizing okay the mind starts to be
okay what are you doing we're supposed
to be going right and you're going left
you start then controlling your mind
start finding more in you know in
yourself and it goes from 40% to a lot
further than that but that's the start
of it though
get to get to the spot where your mind
saying stop wherever that is yeah get
there first and then that's when that
starts to work for you you got to
control yourself in that moment most of
what people do is what we're doing right
now most of what people do is sit down
but is that because they don't feel like
running around because some people like
people who exercise generally you have
to put in a little bit of effort to make
yourself go exercise but a lot of people
who are overweight and sick don't have
enough energy to do that I don't know
about that some of them maybe but I
think some of them just don't have
discipline there's an issue with that as
well there's also an issue with momentum
you're not used to doing it it's not a
part of your life it's not something
you're accustomed to pushing yourself
there's been many many many many many
many many days where I didn't want to
workout I just didn't feel like I had
the energy and I just forced myself and
I think there's very few people out
there that know how to force themselves
that's alert yeah it's a learned skill
yeah that that kind of discipline and
focus you have to have like real rigid
requirements of yourself where you don't
allow yourself to back out of things and
you don't allow yourself to slack off
and I don't think people put those kind
of requirements on themselves as if it's
it is a daily principle of life like
what you must get done you know you must
brush your teeth and yeah exercise for
45 minutes and if you did that I think
you'd be healthier and happier and your
body would perform more smoothly and you
if you require your body to do things
like that I think it rises to the
occasion there are very few people that
have that kind of discipline so because
of that they come up with excuses and
excuses are a giant part of the problem
it's not simply a physical health issue
there's also mental aspects of it and
disciplines a big one I just know way
too many people who are weak mentally
and I can't I can't just chalk it off to
only you know their physical the way
they physically feel because I felt like
a hundred times and then I worked out
and then I felt way better yeah it's
just it's just a fact of life that's
real you know you just can't and I
people don't know how to do that and so
and if you're used to doing this get in
your car sit down drive to the office
sit down
the lunch sit down you know go to the
board meeting sit down get in your car
on the way home sit down get home in
front of the TV sit down then go to the
gym off they don't have any energy you
know that their body's not the body's
like I don't know if it in me to do this
and I don't believe that I don't believe
that I think it's it's a lot of it is
the the mindset these thoughts that we
have we think there are thoughts or
makes it really hard to change them
people meditate try to not think
possible show me somebody has done that
successfully consistently a devotion
everybody the mind thinks thoughts but
here's the distinction if I told you a
hundred years ago we're gonna fly the
moon and back you would call me a
lunatic that's where the term comes from
people still use it it doesn't make any
sense because a lunatic for somebody
thought we gotta move back we've done it
right but if I would have told you a
hundred years ago
that there's gonna be a box in your
pocket and you're gonna pull this thing
out you're gonna hit a couple buttons
and then it's gonna capture invisible
waves that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're gonna
see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're gonna talk to them
you're totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves and when you use your
body in a certain way if I sit like this
I'm gonna channel I'm gonna tap into a
different channel those waves that if
I'm sitting like this kinda like a TV
set if I turn one channel might be a
comedy channel I'm gonna see a lot of
laughter turn another one it's a horror
channel turn another channel it's a
romance channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize that your cloth
do you think are your thoughts there's
nothing unique about your thoughts
they've been around for thousands of
years you're just tapping into them
because of what you're doing with your
body that makes you too fearful or
passion or too courageous or whatever
you're feeling as you go in those states
you get different thoughts so what I
want people to see is that learn how to
just see those thoughts go by it's
learning how to be entertained by those
thoughts because I have crazy thoughts
then but what I've got good at is going
look at that crazy thought That's not me
that's of a mind not your mind cuz if
it's you how do you change you pretty
hard but I really truly know there's I
haven't heard a thought come out of you
that's original
you call them your thoughts but they're
not you've stolen them they've been
around forever
when you see that it's easier to let go
of them and letting go of those thoughts
is one of the ways that you free
yourself and them again the more you do
it just like a muscle you get better and
better and better and all of a sudden
they used to make you crazy or stressed
out or make how many things you'd be
worried about then never came to be and
some people their life is good so they
worry about other people they're never
not worried right so it's really just a
pattern if you want wealth real wealth
is not just money it's emotion that's
like what are we really after in money
you know on money you want pieces of
paper with these pictures of deceased
notables on it you want weaving money
will give you think it'll give you
freedom or security or stability or love
it won't give you a lot it'll get you
sex it won't get you love money right so
really what you're after is the emotion
and so what I want people to get is the
emotion they want down and all it is is
a new habit it's learning to discipline
this mind right by realizing the main
thoughts are out there and letting them
float by and constantly coming back to
what can I love about this what can I
appreciate it's like if you can learn to
love or at least appreciate start to
enjoy the things that used to get upset
about how much freedom would you have
how much more joy to have and I know
people got billions of dollars I've
coached them who is like holy Sh they
live in scarcity all the time when man
I'll never forget he's screaming at his
wife I'm in the meat I mean I'm in the
house and he's screaming his wife
because she spent some money on a bunch
of outfits and stuff like that he's a
multi-billionaire he couldn't spend all
his money in his lifetime and then he's
totally upset at his daughters in her
20s who spent some money too and I'm
like I thought it was afterwards and I
said what do you do this for and what do
you do it for it he's like well it's
just it's the principle thing I said no
the principle thing is do you love these
people and do you want them to have an
abundant life when you have you don't
have one loss but you live like you're
poor you know it's like I finally got
through to them but so many people
that's what I say money doesn't change
you money magnifies who you are so you
want to expand the depth of who you are
and free yourself from suffering by just
knowing it's a pattern of thought and
you can change the pattern of thought
you know you got to discipline yourself
I started looking at Mother Teresa
Gandhi and I was like yo bro Gandhi
would go fast from sex and he was
married he would fast from talking you
know I just started watching these great
people's like all these people fast and
not about fast and like that's not the
peace but they were very disciplined
people and they would not allow their
exterior world to dominate or destroy
their internal world I just like you I
want to get to a place where I can
control me my family members have grown
a loss to uncle cirrhosis of the liver
brilliant man but just drinking drinking
drinking and I was like yo I do not want
to my father was a substance abuser for
years I was like yo I don't want a life
where something else is controlling me
you know like when I left home and said
I don't want to be controlled no more
like I meant that like I don't know
nothing to control me but me and so I
got to put myself under extreme
discipline to make sure I'm free so when
people see me you get up at 3 you don't
drink you don't smoke I'm not doing that
because I think I'm better than a BYOs
oh I think you're gonna go to hell
because you had a drink I just want I
want to control I want freedom and for
me disciplining myself means more
freedom and unless I you discipline
yourself people who I told my son other
dads like your son I do not want you to
have fun I just seen a history of people
who just have fun Christmas Thanksgiving
Halloween know there are the people
every night there are the people who
wind up in a 20s having a great deal of
fun but in a 40s and 50s they were
working for somebody and I'm not saying
I'm wrong with cleaning toilets but they
doing something I want to do for the
rest of a life and they can't retire
because they plays so much you know so
for me
I just look at Venus and Serena Michael
Jackson when he used to like 5 and 6
just dancing all night I just think the
more man discipline himself the greater
don't mean it's gonna happen but the
greater the probability that he has this
sense of freedom I love talking about
discipline because I think so many
people that word has such a negative
connotation around it right it just
sounds bad discipline like you're gonna
feel pain or someone's gonna hurt you or
or you're in trouble for something and I
want to start having you think about it
in a really positive way because
discipline equals freedom 100% it has
been the theme throughout my entire life
is how if you have structured discipline
in your life and you start doing the
things that you don't want to do
especially if you do them first you are
absolutely going to free yourself of all
of the different pain that comes with
not getting your goals accomplished with
comes with that comes with not taking
care of yourself that comes with living
with regret so before way back in my
early 20s and even through my mid-20s
when I would you know I was trying to
create habits around maybe eating right
or habits around working out and let me
tell you habits around getting stuff
done I literally in my head told myself
all the time my mantra at the time was I
never finished anything so what do you
think I did I finished
nothing because that's literally how I
talked to myself well well I never
finished anything this is another thing
I didn't finish so I had to switch that
mantra around and it was also realizing
how important discipline was and how
much freedom came with it and I spent a
lot of time living in agony in my head
and I was tired all the time because I
spent more of my time in my brain
thinking about what I didn't do and
arguing with myself all day long so am I
gonna go to the gym I don't want to go
to the gym you should go to the gym why
aren't you going to the gym you know you
need to go to the gym you're never gonna
get to your goals it's like I was
drained just because of the
conversations I was having with myself
if I would have just gotten disciplined
committed to a time or knew I was going
I could have focused on all of the other
good things that were happening in my
life and just knew this is what I'm
doing it's like just saying okay well
here's what I'm doing so I can forget
about it until the moment that it comes
I'm gonna do it because I'm committing
truly committing to discipline and how
freeing that
and when I started getting a great
discipline habit around all of the
things that I wanted to do I started to
notice how much more free I felt how
much less anxiety I felt how when my
head hit the pillow I felt proud instead
of another day just went by that I'm
further away from my goals and I have
regret and I'm feeling my life race by
me right those are all feeling that do
not feel good that discipline can free
you from people come up to me and they
hole their cellphones at me and they go
these things are ruining our lives right
and my response always is absolutely not
right what's ruining your life is your
inability to exercise discipline around
the use of your technology that's what's
ruining your life because the technology
ends up using you exactly the technology
beautiful I can call my mother in
Australia and see her in literally five
seconds it's amazing how amazing is that
all right so it's your inability to
exercise discipline around the use of
technology is what's running your life
the technology itself is not bad when
you start talking about my brain mmm
it's an organ it's like your heart is an
organ you can speed up your heart you
can slow down your heart you can you
know speed up the brainwaves in your
brain you can slow them down you can
tune in you can tune out yeah we haven't
been given the users manual for the most
powerful tools that we're aware of
that's right and so the great news you
know I know you being an athlete and a
successful businessman you have
disciplined you cannot achieve receive
results without some kind of discipline
and so we know that there's some
fundamental truths to achieving success
and every successful person will tell
you you know and Jim Rohn is I know you
you'll love Jim right so you either pay
the price of discipline or you pay the
price of regret discipline weighs ounces
or Greta weighs tons but the the thing
is can you teach discipline the answer's
yes how you have to have a willing
participant and if the participants
reason why is big enough if they know I
want to achieve X and the reason why the
motive for their action motivation the
motive for their action is a reason
beyond just themselves chances are they
will do
or to achieve that success than if it
was just left up to their own but there
are some people that are born you know
with incredible Drive they just have
this insatiable drive and they'll just
I'll do whatever it takes for the things
that I want and there's other people
that want things but they just don't
have this insatiable drive and this is
where you know I as much as I hate at
school I love to use schools in an algae
they're in the game of life with its
health wealth relationships career
business spirituality fun experiences
you have to decide what level the game
go on to play it is it the great school
level the kindergarten level the high
school level the university level the
pro level because each one of those
levels requires a totally different
mindset and totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely talented but
you're not prepared to practice and
rehearse and drill and fall and fail
forward to the next attempt you will
never make it as a pro you will never
make as a probe isn't this person you'll
never make it as a pro husband or wife
or athlete or musician you just never
will so just get used to that if you're
not prepared to pay the price if you are
prepared to pay the price and you have
the aptitude and the talent now we're
talking about there's some real
potential here and what we don't know is
you know what's in your heart like what
is the fire that stirs you that that you
wake up saying I will do this even when
I don't feel like it I will do whatever
it takes to overcome my temptation for
mediocracy my temptation for excuses my
temptation for reasons and circumstances
to hold me back I won't allow those to
be in my way and if you have that within
you you'll achieve whatever you choose
and so the question you asked before is
how do you develop that start small yeah
start small so if you don't have
discipline show do you show yourself
that you can give yourself one command
and one follow-through so you know what
right now I'm gonna get up I'm going to
do two push-ups right now not not like
later now can you give yourself a simple
command one sit up right now I'm gonna
go get a glass of water
you start with something ridiculous I
learned many as a reduce it to the
ridiculous
hmm so four reduce it to the ridiculous
I start that so can you do that
great will you because that's the
difference right there is that's the
razor's edge can will you will you yeah
great when now now yeah right so if you
develop that skill and specifically from
a brain plasticity a neuroplasticity
perspective as soon as you do that to
give yourself a command and you take the
action you have just created a neural
pattern that you can give yourself a
command and take action now that may be
just be one time but what if you did
that every hour by putting a little bell
on your computer and every hour like if
you were if my computer is open I'd have
every hour it would say it's Volvo clock
it's 1 o clock and I take 60 seconds
just to be in control of my mind
67 don't care where how would you do it
stop takes six breaths so you just get
it just get centered and my on track and
my off track am i doing something I
shouldn't be doing versus a high impact
activity that I need to be doing every
hour I've trained myself to just reset I
didn't always do that so I just started
with one a day right then - sure then
three then it was working so well I said
great let's do this every hour when I
was in high school I must have been
maybe 16 or 17 years old and I went rock
climbing in Eldorado Canyon where I near
where I grew up in Boulder I've been
climbing about 3 or 4 years and I went
to do a climb called t2 now at the time
t2 was a relatively difficult climb and
I went at it with a kind of an arrogant
lack of preparation and I hadn't
prepared for being able to do certain
kinds of finger cracks I figured I'll
figure it out when I get there and I
also didn't pause this is I think about
boldness and discipline I didn't pause
to really double smack double check all
my systems okay so I'm on the fourth
pitch I'm about 400 feet above the
ground I'm going across this slanting
crack system that I'd had
that I started after whether my forearms
started to engorge with blood and lactic
acid which means at some point even if
you're on a big hold your hands are
gonna melt off okay and I'm about to
fall
I'm 400 feet above the ground but it
should be okay because there's
protection
I'm tied into the rope I may take a fall
but I'll get caught for some reason and
to this day I still don't know why my
brain triggered that I should look at my
knot and I looked down at my not my knot
had come untied I had made the mistake
of jet I'm never really thinking about
the best not for certain types of
situations and I tied him with what's a
bowline now the advantage of a bowline
is it's easy to untie if you write the
disadvantage of a Boldin is it's easy to
untie it had come untied as I kept
moving across and it is just hanging in
my harness I'm seconds away from falling
only now I will die I will die if I fall
off my forearms are melting and the knot
had come untied and so I called down to
my partner I said my not coming time was
he gonna do he can't do anything you
just watch me fall to my death and I
there was an old fixed Pete hub in the
rock that we put there from the first to
said an old soft iron Pete on and I
looked at it and I probably had 15-20
seconds before my hands would unwrap if
that maybe 10
I took a runner and I clipped it into
the Piton I clipped the Pete on into my
heart that runner into my harness and
just went please hold
and I let go and it helped
I put in a backup I grabbed the not be
tied it went to the legend didn't
convulsed and I can't I was very calm at
that moment when I got to the ledge I
went into convulsive shaking I was sick
to my stomach for days because of the
the whatever happens chemically what I
learned from that is two things the
first is that when you're in an
unforgiving world the gravity is
unforgiving it doesn't care it never
takes a day off ever and if you make one
mistake it can kill you if it's the
wrong kind of mistake and what I learned
is that sense of yeah I want to do
adventurous things I want to climb rocks
I want to be in Yosemite I want to do
things that get my adrenaline going
I but I need the discipline to always do
all the right preparation to always
think about the right nuts to always be
cross-checking my system so that I can
do those bold things and stay alive in
an unforgiving environment and as you
and I spoke about earlier today I think
that's the rest of I think we are all
heading into an unforgiving environment
where we're gonna have to be both bold
and disciplined the second thing I
learned what if that Piton had not been
there we might not be here together it
was just by chance that that pea tom was
right there and once you realize when
you rewind the tape of your own life is
that there are these crucial moments
where if the luck had gone the other way
you might have gotten killed and so what
you have to do is to always be X putting
those extra disciplines in place because
I was lucky to live and what I took from
that is I never want to have to be lucky
to live again I want to live because of
my discipline not because of my love now
I've got a special bonus clip that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the best life 30 questions
of the day now it's not enough to just
watch a video you have to do something
take action so pull out your worksheets
and let's get to work and if you don't
have the worksheets for this video check
the link in the description to get them
for
question number one where do you need to
have more discipline number two how can
you structure your life properly and
number three what's the thing that you
hate most and how can you do it first
and if you're doing the best life 30
challenge with me give me a hashtag best
five thirty in the comments below so we
could celebrate with you the mind is
getting in your own way if you want to
lose weight you know how to do it you
got to eat less you got to work out more
you will lose weight why are you not
doing it self discipline your mind is
getting in your way what I see self
discipline is a positive I think self
discipline has a really negative
connotation a lot of times I think in a
lot of the messages that people are
putting out it comes across as this
really negative thing like you have to
force yourself to do all of the stuff
that you really hate and it's gonna suck
but you have to keep going you got to do
it you got to be disciplined if you're
not disciplined you suck everything's
terrible it just comes across as really
negative forcing yourself to do stuff
that doesn't resonate with me I see self
discipline as a really positive thing I
think it's really helpful I think it's
amazing and beautiful and golden let's
look at weight as an example I am the
lowest weight that I've been all year
I'm on a routine it's working the
specific strategies that don't really
matter
one intimate it fasting so I'll only
have water and a coffee until noon and
then after that I'll start eating I do
that seven days a week I run for thirty
minutes usually at night while I'm
watching the show with my wife seven
days a week and then six days a week
I'll restrict my calories not really
forcing myself not to eat food just not
eating Doritos and not eating junk right
eating healthy food six days a week and
then Saturdays I get to do what I want
six days a week those are the strategies
that I use it may seem like torture but
it's not and the thing that helps me get
through it is the mindset because the
positive of all of this is I'm losing
weight I'm feeling great I'm making
progress I'm super pumped that I'm
getting closer to my goal I feel amazing
about myself so I think self-discipline
usually it seems to focus just on the
action that you just have to grind your
way through it without and not focus on
the mission of what you're trying to
accomplish and how beautiful and
wonderful that is
and so yes some of it might suck right
but you're moving towards something
amazing and beautiful so I think people
just focus too much on the negative part
of it and and if you force yourself to
do something that you hate you can only
do it for so long before you give up if
you can't tie it into the bigger picture
of what you're trying to accomplish then
you will give up and you will quit and
you will feel terrible and then I think
having other people yell at you but how
you need to have self-discipline doesn't
actually help I think it actually makes
it worse because you develop the
identity for yourself of I don't have
any self-discipline you can build it
it's not that difficult to do in my
perspective in my view all you need to
do is make sure that you have a really
strong why make sure that you have an
outcome that you are really looking
forward to and you love doing and then
the process itself how do you make the
process as enjoyable as possible how do
you make the process just not absolutely
suck every single day going in right if
you figure that out then you win if you
want to join the best life 30 challenge
click the link right here below me or if
you want even more videos on how to
build your discipline check out the
playlist right there next to me continue
to believe and I'll see you soon